in the world of gaming having every
Advantage possible can mean the
difference between Victory and defeat
while the fox over on the Xbox side have
had the Arsenal enhanced by the Xbox
Elite controllers the PlayStation Nation
had always needed to depend on third
party Solutions well that time is over
now that the Dual sense Edge is upon us
the first ever high performance Ultra
customizable controller developed by
Sony its aim is to provide the H in-game
play by inviting players to craft their
own unique gaming experience tailored to
their playstyle it might look like a
spruced up dual sense controller but
this technological Marvel packs plenty
of both its hardware and software
options
right out the box players will get the
dual sense H wireless controller a USB
braided cable three sets of caps for the
analog sticks two sets of back buttons
the connector housing and of course that
Sleek carrying case that even allows
charging while keeping your new toy safe
in terms of customizability the Dual
sense age lives up to its promise of
bespoke adjustments for any play style
the three swappable stick caps deliver
the right comfort with excellent grip
and stability be it the standard High
Dome or low Dome options and can be
easily changed for every situation need
additional inputs that are easily
accessible tack on those back buttons
and configure their inputs so your
fingers never have to get messy the
triggers travel distance and date zones
can also be adjusted to your liking as
well going from Full presses to hair
triggers so players can enjoy faster
inputs in competitive FPS games enjoy a
reduction of dead zone for precise
throttle control in racing games and the
Dual sense Edge retains all of the
awesome bells and whistles that makes it
more original predecessor such a big hit
and with the braided cable and connector
housing you're never going to worry
about battery or losing your connection
at the most demanding of moments as for
the worrisome issue of stick drift this
bad boy has the capacity for replaceable
stick module which will be extremely
helpful in prolonging its longevity next
up we're going to be talking about the
software options that make the Dual
sense Edge such a Marvel but before that
here's some cool stuff from our friends
over at MSI this video is brought to you
by MSI meet the summit e16 flip
featuring the latest 11th gen Intel Core
i7 processor RTX 30 series graphics and
a 16 inch QHD plus touchscreen panel
with a 360 degree hinge better yet it
lets you unleash maximum productivity
with up to 11 hours of battery life at
just 2 kilograms the summit e16 flip
offers unprecedented performance and
functionality allowing you to work and
play anywhere anytime on the software
side of things there's much to look
forward to as well the aforementioned
remapping and deactivating or button
inputs can come in handy for those
requiring a certain setup while your aim
can be further fine-tuned by adjusting
stick sensitivity and dead zones
vibration intensity is also another
options that can be changed to suit your
liking once these ideal settings have
been found players can then save them to
Unique profiles and make every title
more convenient to play with the
dedicated function buttons found below
the sticks can make it easy to swap
between profiles happening in just
seconds adjusting your game volume and
chat balance is easy or you can access
the controller profile settings for
Rapid adjustments at any time there is
zero doubt that the Dual sense Edge is
the top tier option when it comes to
gaming on the PlayStation 5 but the
question of whether it is worth it truly
depends on your needs the edit buttons
are always nice for those looking for
more convenient or faster inputs while
the travel distance adjustments will
make a big difference in Shooters after
that the robust software customization
and how easy it is to actually switch
its components around and this makes the
Dual sense Edge a truly game-changing
accessory for the PlayStation 5. however
for its price point it is a hefty
investment for most of the general
audience that is enjoying their console
experience unless you are truly devoted
to the type of games that will benefit
from its customizability or find added
use for all the other features this
might just be a costlier dual sense
controller that just so happened to have
a lower battery life this is a want more
than a need but for anyone looking to
invest in hundreds of hours of intense
gaming on the PlayStation 5 the Dual
sense Edge certainly makes sense if you
are looking for the pardon the pun H
against your opponents and whatever
challenges their lies ahead it is
exciting that the PlayStation Community
now has an elevated controller
experience available just be ready to
pay the price for such Innovations if
you have any questions leave them in the
comment section and I'll do my best to
get to them follow us on our socials and
don't forget to hit the like And
subscribe button it goes a long way and
if you want to see more stuff check this
out
foreign
[Music]